E aí
é porque você não tem pai se ele não
morreu que me fez essa pergunta foi um
colega lá da 4ª série O Thiago quando eu
tinha apenas dez anos de vida mesmo
lembranças daquela época são bem vagas
mas aquele dia foi muito marcante
exatamente por esse rápido e
despropositado de algo que eu tive com
ele me lembro que na ocasião toda turma
se apresentou para os pais no palco da
escola cantando uma música recitando um
poema e na sequência entregando uma
colagem sobre o Dia dos Pais que fizemos
na aula de educação artística
Não me recordo muito bem o contexto do
porque ele me questionar aquilo mas
acredito que tenha sido pelo fato de
minutos antes enquanto ele estava
agarrado a cintura de seu pai tem me
perguntado onde estavam meu pai e eu ter
lhe respondido que não tinha pai ele com
sua curiosidade de criança insistiu
questionando se meu pai havia morrido
tendo prontamente a resposta de que não
daí então veio a fatídica pergunta por
que você não tem pai se ele não morreu
e olha eu confesso que agora no meu
corre explicação que vem para ele até
porque quase 25 anos depois desse dia
continuo tropeçando nas peças desse
complexo quebra-cabeça foi lá em 1996
que descobriu de sabor em ver meu pai
pela última vez ela fim de tarde na
calçada em frente à estação de trem do
Bairro em que morava na periferia de São
Paulo ele já vivia bem pouco de vez em
quando aparecer no portão de casa para
falar com a minha mãe e com ainda no
menos frequência me levava para dar uma
volta no bar onde ele se reunia com os
amigos nos esbarramos por acaso naquele
dia derradeiro Mas foi como nos
encontros anteriores que eu tenho na
memória rápido e frio nos despedimos ele
foi para um lado sozinho e Eu segui meu
caminho com a minha mãe jamais imaginei
que aquela seria a última vez que eu
veria na verdade penúltima já que houve
um breve encontro 21 anos depois quando
eu já era adulto e mesmo com o
reencontro e o perdão Genuíno é sabido e
compreendido que os dias perdidos ficar
o caminho sem qualquer possibilidade em
Serem recuperados não é que meu pai
viajou a trabalho e voltou uma semana
depois entendeu
eu fiquei sem uma das presenças mais
importantes para minha formação enquanto
o ser humano quase 8 mil Dias 2000
semanas 250 meses por muito tempo
Cheguei a pensar Como assim a pessoa
saber que tem um filho crescendo por aí
os perigos de uma periferia e ainda
assim desaparecer nunca ligar ou enviar
carta ou mandar sinal de fumaça Como
assim não fazer a menor questão em saber
se aquele pequeno ser no caso eu o filho
está com fome sede frio ou se
simplesmente está vivo isso claro Sem
contar os muitos aniversários sem um
abraço os diversos natais sem meu papai
noel particular e os incontáveis dias
dos pais olhando meus amigos brincando
de bola com seus heróis sem saber onde
estava o meu Casei me formei tive meu
primeiro dia de trabalho minha filha
nasceu tudo sem meu pai por perto para
dividir a emoção dos principais
instantes da jornada humana comigo
inúmeras foram as passagens de ano
olhando para os povos não sabe
Perguntando a Deus e eu tinha feito de
tão grave para ser abandonado ainda
criança por um homem que ao menos
Teoricamente e de acordo com as leis
divinas e a ordem natural da vida
deveria me Amar Incondicionalmente
enquanto eu vivesse
e existem três formas de abandono
paterno um material que é quando lhe
falta suplementos básicos de
sobrevivência como alimentação e Socorro
diante de uma enfermidade grave
dois intelectual quando ele é cerceado o
direito primário aos estudos e três
afetivo quando o pai não aceita o filho
e não o trata como prioridade
renunciando a presença a convivência do
dia-a-dia
eu gabaritei fui contemplado com todas
as formas um característico abandono
completo que é quando a essa omissão no
cuidado e na criação do filho E
negligência na assistência moral
psíquica e social É mas não sou nem de
longe caso raro exceção porque a gente
vive no Brasil uma verdadeira epidemia
abandono paterno e como parte
majoritária da população não se permite
em parar e analisar o tamanho do impacto
negativo que esse problema tem o
andamento da sociedade no contexto mais
abrangente e médio e longo prazo
seguimos reclamando maquiando e até
endossando mesmo que inconscientemente
esse obstáculo crônico como se ele fosse
inaceitável porém não prioritário para
se ter uma ideia dados mais recentes do
Conselho Nacional de Justiça diz que
cinco milhões de brasileiros não possuem
o nome do pai na certidão de nascimento
já o levantamento feito pelo IBGE aponta
que já temos quase 12 milhões e mãe só
no país ou seja mulheres que criam seus
filhos sozinhas desse montante de
mulheres que sustentam a casa e tem
filhos menores de 14 anos
56 por cento está abaixo da linha da
pobreza no parâmetro adotado pelo Banco
Mundial e se essa mulher foi preta ou
parda o índice atinge o patamar de 64
por cento e essa parada de ter um filho
para chamar de meu não pode ser encarada
com uma trivial brincadeira é Nossa
marca no Mundo é Nossa continuidade é
nosso perpetuar a espécie no âmbito de
valores e ideais em 2014 e quando nasceu
minha filha Laís sabia que eu tinha um
importante papel a cumprir enquanto
cidadão educador mas também foi ali que
me dei conta de que eu não fazia a menor
ideia de como era seu pai a falta de
referência para criá-la de ter uma fonte
para beber e se inspirar de comune
transformar na figura de segurança que
ela precisa enfim reflexões que me
deixaram com medo de não acertar a minha
vez de não saber orientar e transmitir
valores básicos impor limites dosar e
até ser carinhoso e Isso acabou sendo o
meu primeiro estalo sobre o quão nocivo
pode ser o abandono paterno esse aqui da
mesma forma é responsável por semear
características extremamente
prejudiciais à nossa existência para o
resto da vida uma vez que parte
relevante dos filhos abandonados esteja
mais propícios a quando adultos e tem
mais inseguros anciosos agressivos
pessimistas isolados e exageradamente
introvertidos com baixa autoestima sem
conhecimento da palavra limite incluindo
diz respeito aos pais e outras figuras
de autoridade' com crenças limitantes do
tipo não posso não mereço não é para mim
danos psicológicos muitas vezes
irreversíveis que em Cadeia podem levar
a insônia a distúrbios alimentares baixo
rendimento escolar dificuldade de
aprendizagem em segurança para
estabelecer vínculos afetivos síndrome
do pânico depressão e claro até mesmo ao
suicídio estamos falando de um impacto
psicossocial com impressionante força em
áreas como segurança educação saúde
trabalho Assistência Social sistema
carcerário e até economia o Ministério
Público de São Paulo divulgou em 2016 um
estudo em que afirma a cada três menores
infratores no estado dois não tem o pai
dentro de casa respondo fato de que sem
a figura o período em que ocorre a
construção da identidade da
personalidade o filho cresce mais
impulsivo e com menos ferramentas e
estratégias para lidar com adversidades
que imploram por maior equilíbrio
resiliência dito isso a conclusão
aparentemente mais óbvia é de que o
homem que deixa seu filho à própria
sorte sem olhar para trás é o maior e
principal responsável pelo abandono e
sim isso É de fato indiscutível mas a
gente também pode desviar um segundo da
análise mais simplista do senso comum e
partir para uma reflexão pouco proposta
de que ele é sim o maior e principal
responsável pelo abandono mas que talvez
não seja o único e que mesmo sem
perceber todos enquanto sociedade temos
Nossa parcela de responsabilidade nesse
tipo de Conduta contando inclusive com a
lamentável cumplicidade da própria
Justiça da mídia no jornalismo de nós
homens e mulheres do marketing da
publicidade só para citar alguns tudo é
coletivo as opiniões importam somos
influenciados e vamos ouvimos e vemos
seja digital offline e Mentiras piadas
ou crenças ditas repetidamente ao longo
de gerações acabam se tornando
culturalmente verdades como por exemplo
afirmações do tipo amanhã mais que mesmo
quando dica então de humor fomenta a
convicção de que a responsabilidade
maior sobre um filho a exclusivamente da
mãe quando o obviamente não é nem a mais
nem tem responsabilidade maior ou menor
o nível de amor é incondicional a ambos
e as obrigações devem ser
igualitariamente divididas entre ambos
mãe e pai é imprescindível livrar a
paternidade de amarras que a colocam
como coadjuvantes na vida dos filhos
trazendo alguns pontos primeiro Veja sua
cultura do provedor em que se vende a
ideia de que o pai não tem condições de
criar disseminar ensinamentos e valores
mas sim apenas contribuir
financeiramente o que junta ultrapassada
a frase isso é coisa de mulher o palco é
cuidado de afeto também acesso ao campo
de outro transtorno social grave que é o
machismo segundo o uso de termos como
ele é um super pai ou Nossa como ele
ajuda a ela também precisam deixar
imediatamente nosso vocabulário uma vez
que avaliza a presença facultativa e o
homem precisa ser tratado como um adulto
que é se tem filho não é ajudante ou
menos ainda o pai fora da curva apenas
cumprem com suas simples e básico
obrigação porque não existe super pai
existe pai e só nada do que uma pessoa
fizer para o seu filho ser a favor ou
menos ainda motivo para pause elogio
Ninguém merece confete por criar o
próprio filho até porque ou você é pai
ou somente tem filho terceiro temos
ainda o fato de um novo relacionamento
poder impactar frequência do filho na
vida do homem que por algum motivo não
se mostra disposto a dividir seu tempo
de presença entre um amor incondicional
e uma nova paixão colocando o pequeno e
são EA companheira recém-chegada como
prioridade quarto também não há como
esquecer de que numa comunidade
moralista como a nossa não é aceita em
pleno século 21 que o pai fica com a
guarda do filho como se de novo ele não
fosse tão importante quanto a mãe na
vida e cuidados com a cria e também como
se a própria mãe não pudesse optar em
abrir mão da guarda porque igualmente o
moralismo julga a mulher que opte deixar
o pequeno com um homem quinto e o papai
nas embalagens brinquedos comidinhas
fraldas e lencinhos perfumes Cadê amigos
marketeiros e publicitários é como se
aparentemente na visão das empresas a
figura paterna só existisse no dia ou
mês dos Pais quase não há menção ou
menos ainda valorização situação tão
subliminarmente aceita que nem é comuns
próprios homens perceberem que estão
sendo preterido da vida dos seus filhos
Aí eu pergunto tornar invisível ou
segregar a figura paterna é realmente o
caminho mais assertivo ao se vender o
conceito de campanha é de família ou
filhos felizes parece que não sexto e o
espaço o trocador de fraldas no toalete
masculino em
eu não ainda não é uma realidade
integral nos estabelecimentos ao menos
do Brasil
Ah e por fim sétimo não há como deixar
de mencionar o fato de termos leis
extremamente permissivas que não punem
com Rigor e exemplo os homens que
abandonam seus filhos vídeo fato de até
pouco tempo atrás a mulher que fosse na
justiça reivindicar a pensão de um pai
que subiu no mundo ela mesmo tinha que
encontrar o endereço desse homem e levar
o tribunal porque nem isso o poder
público se prontificaram em fazer aliás
ainda no campo do que manda a lei
licença-paternidade de 5 a 20 dias
licença maternidade de 4 a 6 meses
situação que reforça a defasada figura
do Patriarca mantenedor que ou incapaz
de cuidar do filho que acaba de virar o
mundo ou é um simples figurante
completamente dispensável já na primeira
infância algo que de novo nos remédios
até o machismo já que de forma implícita
da entender que a mulher é sim obrigada
a sozinha abdicar de absolutamente tudo
para se dedicar ao filho como se fosse a
única responsável legal por ele quando
na verdade poderia ter osso o pai
durante um período mais justo um tempo
mais justo para dividir igualitariamente
as tarefas além de receber apoio em seu
período também por pério que muitas
vezes não é um mar de rosas é a figura
do pai novamente ignorada é a figura da
mãe novamente explorado além do
necessário
ninguém absolutamente ganha com isso
percebe o quanto todos os dias e por
todos os lados excluímos ou abrandamos a
responsabilidade da figura paterna na
vida de seus filhos o com a premissa do
filho só tem mãe potencializa máximas
como o pai não é importante o pai uma
pessoa como outra qualquer o pai uma
figura dispensável e decorativa entenda
que isso tudo se converte no argumento
de venda da ideia de que a mãe tem mais
direito sobre o filho e naturalmente
condiciona a figura masculina uma
perigosa zona de conforto que o faz
acreditar ser menos responsável por algo
que na verdade é sim grande protagonista
esse esse senso de responsabilidade não
chega o filho não é somente por um
desvio de retidão ou calor das emoções a
um vasto contexto histórico por de trás
da atitude que envolve o abandono
inclusive o perdão ao meu pai que por
muitos anos foi motivo de trauma e
revolta se desenhou dentro de mim a
partir do momento em que me permiti
olhar um pouco além da minha própria
biografia
e em função disso não é nada saudável
continuar tirando das costas do homem
uma obrigação que é somente dele de
forma pessoal e intransferível como bem
Sabemos um homem com deslize de índole
somado a todos os fatores estruturais
que Eu mencionei que o exime do
compromisso paterno e ainda somado a
impunidade no estado será sempre um
prato cheio para transgressão de
princípios é urgente a necessidade em
compreender de forma coletiva e
individual que a presença do pai na
formação humana é insubstituível e
fundamental para a construção de uma
sociedade mais saudável quanto mais
refletirmos sobre Nossa contribuição
individual acerca de problemas coletivos
maiores as possibilidades de resolução
no caso do abandono paterno quanto mais
Pais Presentes mais filhos saberão O que
é e como para treinar somos fermentos
para uma boa ou má reverberação de algo
endossamos o crescimento da massa do
todo e sim a um marketing de emboscada
histórico que a face os filhos uma
armadilha que todos caímos reproduzirmos
dia após dia
e por todos esses motivos
proporcionam a paternidade diferente a
minha própria filha tornou-se urgente
para mim particularmente Afinal é
preciso devolver ao mundo o melhor de
nós mesmo que não tenhamos recebido o
benefício semelhante a nossa vez
lembre-se por se tratar de uma pneumonia
silenciosa não cabe mais nos referimos
ao abandono paterno apenas com
reclamações chacotas ou ironias o tema
pede seriedade uma revisão de Conduta
Global se faz extremamente urgente Ok
grife mas eu com isso exatamente meu
amigo minha amiga e você o que tem a ver
com isso qual tem sido o seu papel Nossa
importante questão é o alguém que
fomenta a presença ou a pessoa que mesmo
sem perceber endossa ausência e não ao
que ser feito com o até ontem mas com o
a partir de hoje sim